ولقد رأيت الأرقام ولا أستطيع أن
أشارككم إياها بعد ولكن عندما
ينتهي هذا يمكننا إجراء مناقشة جادة
عندما يكون ضباب الحرب وراءنا ولكني
مقتنع على الرغم من أن كل
وفاة مدنية وخاصة الأطفال
هي  مأساة ولا نريد أن نراها
بأعداد مقارنة إذا قارنت
إسرائيل بالكمال
فسنفشل بالطبع، لكن إذا قارنت إسرائيل
بالجيوش الغربية الأخرى التي
تقاتل الإرهابيين في المناطق الحضرية المبنية على ما
أعتقد  لن تكون نتائج الإسراء
سيئة. في المقارنة، على العكس من ذلك،
أعتقد أنه سيتبين أن جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي قد
فعل كل ما هو
ممكن إنسانيًا لمحاولة حماية
المدنيين الأبرياء، ومن الصعب جدًا
تصديق ذلك خاصة في اليوم الذي يقوم فيه
أحد منتجينا  فقد تسعة أفراد
من عائلته، تسعة أفراد من عائلته
لم يكونوا أعضاء في كاماس، وليسوا
أعضاء في حركة الجهاد الإسلامي الفلسطينية،
وليسوا أعضاء في أي مجموعة، فقط تسعة
أشخاص يحاولون فقط أن يعيشوا
حياتهم أولاً وقبل كل شيء، أنا أعرب عن
حزني له وتعاطفي  لكن إذا
رأيت تقريرك بشكل صحيح وأرجو
تصحيحي إذا قلت شيئًا خاطئًا
حدث في شمال غزة أه في
مدينة غزة حيث طلبنا بالفعل منذ شهر من
جميع المدنيين المغادرة
ومعظمهم فعلوا إذا كان هناك حوالي 1,200,000
شخص هناك  لم يتبق سوى بضع عشرات
الآلاف ويجب على المرء أن
يسأل نعم كان لديهم فرصة كبيرة
للمغادرة. لا أعرف ماذا حدث ليس
لدي الظروف المحددة. أعلم أن
هناك قتالًا مميتًا يدور الآن في
الشمال لا يزال بين الحين والآخر.  هؤلاء الإرهابيون من جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي و و و
و حماس نعم،
ولا نريد أن نرى أي شخص محاصرًا في
تبادل إطلاق النار ولكن لماذا لم يستجيبوا
للنصيحة ويغادروا المنطقة،
لا يمكنك إلقاء اللوم عليهم، هناك الآن قتال
ألومهم ولكنك  ألا يمكن أن يكون هناك
قتال في الجنوب الآن أين
هم، أقصد أنني كنت أسأل هذا منذ
7 أكتوبر، أين من
المفترض أن
يذهب هؤلاء الأشخاص، لذا في البداية كان الأمر أسهل
لأن القتال كان يتركز في
الشمال وقد سألنا للتو
كان ذلك أمرًا
بسيطًا نسبيًا، فهو لا يعني أنه بسيط تمامًا
ولكنه بسيط نسبيًا، فقط اذهب جنوب نهر
النهر ولكننا الآن
أكثر تحديدًا لأنه
أكثر تعقيدًا في الجنوب الذي
حددناه بالفعل  مناطق أه في
الجنوب هي مناطق أكثر أمانًا وهي
خاصة هناك عدد منها أه لقد
شاركنا الخرائط معها
مع الولايات المتحدة وقد تمت مشاركتها
أيضًا مع الأمم المتحدة
والمنظمات الإنسانية الأخرى استمع علينا أن
نضرب كاماس  inhan un لديهم
بنية تحتية عسكرية قوية هناك
لديهم شبكة من الأنفاق إذا
أردنا تدمير آلة حماس العسكرية
وعلينا أن نتحرك في الجنوب
كذلك أه كبار قادة كاماس
هناك تحت الأرض في كانون
لا يمكننا أن نذهب إلى هناك ولكن من خلال الذهاب إلى هناك وهزيمة
حماس، سنبذل أيضًا
جهدًا كبيرًا مرة أخرى لمحاولة
حماية أرواح المدنيين، ولهذا السبب
نحث الناس هناك الآن على الانتقال إلى
المناطق الجديدة التي  لقد حددنا ذلك
ومع بدء العملية البرية
يمكنني أن أؤكد لكم أن
طرق الهروب والممرات الإنسانية
التي ستسمح للمدنيين بالخروج من
طريق الضرر ستظل
موجودة